hello everybody welcome to another
python mathematics and finance
indicators tutorial video uh in this
video in the next few videos we're gonna
be talking about these keltner channels
so what are the kettler channels
obviously uh oftentimes you're gonna see
them denoted as k-e-l-t
uh they're very similar to bollinger
bands in their appearance
and they're also just like bollinger
bands volatility-based bands that are
going to kind of operate above and below
an exponential moving average line so
there's going to be three lines to them
so if you've ever seen a picture of them
you would probably ask well what's the
difference between these keltner
channels
and bull ninja bands so bollinger bands
if you recall we did already have a
tutorial on how to do those
uh bollinger bands are using standard
deviation to give
uh the width basically whereas these
keltner channels they're using
uh atr or average true range and if you
don't recall that we also had a
tutorial on those and that is
calculated like standard deviate like
both of those would be
um measure of variance but standard
deviation
is a little bit different or a lot of it
different than average true range
and if you don't recall average to range
which is basically the largest price
difference between bars
so usually the high amount is low but it
could also be like the high minus the
previous closed price and so on
anyway the keltner channels also make
use of an ema so an exponential moving
average rather than a simple moving
average which the bollinger bands use
uh that said uh you can of course
instead of using an sma in your
calculation of bollinger bands using ema
it's not like the end of the world that
you made that simple change
plenty of people do it but anyway
those are the differences and generally
because of the standard deviation here
you'll find
one that if the stock has made massive
changes over a period of time
standard deviation won't really keep up
whereas average true range will actually
keep up a little bit better
yet at the same time standard deviations
a lot a little bit more volatile in its
movements than eurofind
atr is so with that how do we actually
calculate these bad boys
well as i said it comes in three lines
the top line is going to be your time
frame ema so whatever time frame you
choose
there um i forget which one what we're
using at
i want to say we're doing a 20 period
ema
and then it's gonna be plus two times
the atr
average true range uh and then you're
using a secondary time frame there and i
believe we're gonna use a 10.
again it's up to your discretion however
you want to do you could do 2020 or 10
10 or
50 50 or whatever the heck you want to
do middle line is just a simple
it's a simple exponential moving average
uh it's just an exponential moving
average
for whatever that time frame is and then
the bottom line is going to be that time
frame minus two times the atr
of tf2 so our atr of
using the tf2 so that's the calculation
now let's actually look at
a couple examples and i'm also going to
compare them
uh with you guys to bollinger bands
so the first one this is the keltner
channels and we're gonna plot
up uh let's do starbucks that's a good
one to start with since that's what we
usually use
so this is our starbucks uh keltner
channels
so as you can see they do look very
similar to
um our bollinger bands so similar in
fact
let's go ahead and plot the bollinger
bands so i've got a bollinger band
plotting here so we'll plot up starbucks
i'm gonna move it over here so i don't
get lost so here's our bollinger bands
so the
way you'll tell them at least for now is
these ones are white these ones
are cyan so one um
you know you can change up like your
width that you wanted i'm trying to
think of
uh what stock looked good with our
current settings under bollinger bands
let's see
probably yeah ebay was one that we used
so let's plot up ebay and compare the
two of them
so that's ebay on that one for bollinger
bands and then
i don't know what i did with here we go
put this up here
and we'll pull out ebay now to get the
keltner channel
so here is ebay's keltner channel and
then here is the bollinger bands
so as you can see uh fairly similar
at least with ebay if anything maybe the
bollinger bands
are doing a slightly better job even
with ebay
but then another one and this is what i
mean with
uh why i don't like bollinger bands so
much is you saw how good it worked with
ebay
then say we want to do another company
like maybe apple bollinger bands
we'll move this over and you can see
that the bollinger bands we almost don't
even see them
right they are there though like you
know if we zoom in here here they are
and then we'll go to apple on the actual
keltner channel you know see that apple
actually lines up
quite right and i think this really
brings home the point
in why bollinger bands are not
necessarily the best idea because
they're going to be different with every
stock it's almost like they're not
normalized
you know so so your settings would have
to in theory
change depending on what stock you're
doing unless of course we did something
horribly wrong in our calculation of
bollinger bands which is totally
possible if anybody you know sees what
we maybe did wrong or why this would
even occur
feel free to let me know um so anyway
um so that's a little bit of a
comparison of
uh a or ap bollinger bands in the
keltner channels and some of their
differences overall i mean they're fair
at least when bollinger bands are
working uh it's very similar
but anyway i actually like held their
channels better and i think at least
with the calculation of them it makes a
lot more sense to me in my mind
why that why they're even a used
indicator
but notably uh bollinger bands are far
more popular so
interestingly enough now um so
that's kind of like your introduction to
these uh keltner channels
what they do how they're used uh
generally uh with bands like this you'll
see
um like with apple here like we're
now looking at keltner channels and this
is a great example of what i mean though
see like apple went from
you know just this tiny price of you
know around 60 bucks or so
and now is like way higher so it's
standard deviation
isn't necessarily the best use uh even
though i think i believe that we were it
was like a moving standard deviation
but maybe it wasn't so it never actually
got any thicker
right so it's always using like the same
kind of deviation width
so maybe that was our problem in our our
calculation of it or something
um anyway so like when you get you know
like a breakout like what happened here
uh where price you know broke out here
so that's kind of a very bullish signal
and again it broke out really strong
here very bullish signal
broke continued breaking out and then it
went ahead and broke out all the way
down here very bearish signal and
continued on
so that's kind of a signal way that you
can use them as like a signal for what's
to come same thing there was a breakout
down here as well where it went below
the bands
and a breakout again above the bands up
there so anyway that's uh some of the
signals so in the next video what we're
going to be talking about is
how to calculate this within python and
then how to actually plot it up on the
chart just like this
uh you just won't have the macd
indicator down here so
that sounds interesting to you guys stay
tuned in the next video as always thanks
for watching thanks for the support and
all the subscriptions
until next time